Я слышала что здесь мы можем
соприкоснуться с природой искупаться на
краю водопада с сумасшедшим обрывом
поужинать в историческом поезде и
полетать над всеми этими видами на
вертолёте Для чего вы пролетели половину
земного шара чтобы оказаться здесь если
честно для того чтобы лично встретиться
с маргулан калечим получить от него
новые знания в самой удалённой части
земного шара в Африке
Oh
просьба отнестись к этому обучению
совсем по-другому Вот это обучение оно
реально другое Цель нашего манда
максимально эффективно провести время
получив а глубокие знания новых друзей и
яркие впечатления на всю жизнь 7 дней
совместной жизни - это кусочек нашей
жизни которое мы посвящаем друг другу по
сути А кому е мы поща токо дру 7 дней
поэтому Давайте чтобы этот отрезок
маленький маленькая жизнь которая
пройдёт совместная Наша маленькая жизнь
чтобы она прошла прекрасная чтобы мы об
этом вспоминали всегда с теплотой
Давайте нацелить на то чтобы извлечь
максимальную пользу и в виде знаний и в
виде друзей и в виде ярких эмоциональных
впечатлений Спасибо до завтра
[музыка]
Меня зовут осель Сагатова я киноактриса
из Казахстана Я из труни город Ашхабад Я
приехал из Северного города Сургут там у
нас сейчас совсем другая погода я с
Красноярска занимаемся поставкой
телекоммуникационного оборудования А
родом из Алматинской области занимаюсь в
частности недвижимостью участками
коммерческими объектами Я из Латвии Я
предприниматель У меня холдинговая
группа предприятий родился в Чимкенте
вырос в Алмате я узнала об этой поездке
от команды маргулана кальви в частности
от Вовы про эту поездку я узнала ещё
осенью будучи в поездке также с
маргуланом Калиевич в Исландии я
изначально в исландию собирался но она
не состоялась так как визу не одобрили
поэтому дальше узнал о том что поедем в
Африку и поехал сюда про поездку я узнал
из калда который был в Дубае и встретил
очень замечательных людей Марч и его
команда создаёт очень крутые
качественные поездки решил конечно не
пропустить и приехать в Африку Я хочу
выйти на новый уровень и преодолеть
прежде всего ментальные ограничения на
этой поездки Я даже боюсь представить
Какие у меня будут целит
и Тут ещё есть в программе такое то что
мы будем ставить цели на 2025 год и с
мудростью маргулана Калиевич Я думаю мы
это с лёгкостью
достигнем Когда вы преследуете чужую
цель Вы по сути отдаёте свою свободу
этому человеку а что такое свобода
Свобода - это время плюс энергия свобод
это время плюс энергия То есть вы
что-то делаете не то вы тратите время вы
тратите энергию А что такое время плюс
энергия это Это жизнь время плюс энергия
- это ваша жизнь поэтому преследуя чужую
цель вы просто сжигается свою жизнь или
жертвует своей жизнью ради кого-то и вот
здесь очень важно поэтому определить чем
не заниматься
на самом деле последнее время я
испытываю странное состояние как будто
мир остановился и жизнь проходит мимо
меня год был
сложный было много проектов Я не мог
найти ответы на свои вопросы смотрел ю
каналы общался с разными людьми но не
смог найти всё равно ответ на свои
вопросы пробовал себя в разных сферах но
ничего не зажигает как
раньше и я приехал сюда с надеждой найти
ответ на свои вопросы и разрушить все
стереотипы
[музыка]
Ja SA
Это было очень круто Спасибо ксени всё
она теперь моя
сестра прыгать Вообще супер классно
мыслей не было никаких
че было страшно и всё ко Это полёт птицы
на доле секунды это полёт птицы в каждом
из нас есть Ген птицы и вот здесь он
получает своё наслаждение Каждый должен
это сделать по уровню эмоций было
максимально Хорошо я это сделал
получилось прыщ пря кайфо удовольствия
больше получил и Всем рекомендую не
бояться и закрывать свои страхи и
ставить
галочки У меня всё
[музыка]
любой
дискомфорт любое страдание любая боль
любое неудовольствие неудовлетворение
отсутствие счастья это всё не
соответствие вашего представления
существующей реальности заметьте Чем
отличается счастливый человек и мудрый
человек от других чем они отличаются
мудрый или счастливый человек потому что
мудрый человек не может быть
несчастливым мудрый человек как правило
он принимает этот мир таким какой он
есть со всеми плохими вещами и хорошими
вещами при этом он у него что
смирение смирение он совсем смиряется Он
всё принимает при этом он на всё смотрит
с
любовью ничего не отторгает он понимает
что всё является частичкой его То есть
он
вот он огонь слон небо вы это всё одно
соответственно он не может одну часть
себя любить а другую часть не любить и
благодаря этому что бы с ним не
произошло он это понимает и Воспринимает
как блага у него не вызывает ничего у
него его в душе ничего не царапает у
него нету дискомфорта несогласия борьбы
и так далее Если у вас есть борьба
неудача невезение
проблемы переживания тревоги
беспокойства
сомнения значит проблема у вас не
соответствие вашего представления
картинке мира Потому что когда у вас Чем
чётче будет соответствие тем знаете
гладко будет идти в ваша жизнь просто
гладко всё будет происходить как будто
само собой вы знаете когда вы чтото
делать неправильно Вам приходится
толкать при
ули когда А у вас чёткое представление
оно как бы всё случается само собой вот
условно ты Поставил цель и взял весло и
гребёт гребёт гребёт гребёт изучаешь
техники гребли левой рукой так правой
рукой так потом так ты изучаешь потом
нюансы куча куча движений
а мудрый человек Он смотрит наблюдает
смотрит за течением и весно берёт
чуть-чуть раз под грёб выбрал течение
которое само его принесёт к цели надо
течение выбирать А что такое течение
течение - это сила когда обстоятельства
работают на тебя когда время работает на
тебя когда место работает на тебя когда
ты довольствуется малым И когда ты вот
это всё используешь которое я говорил
вам источники силы вас самих выносит к
вашей цели ваш самих цель сама к вам
приходит
друзья такое ощущение что рядом с
палаткой наша что-то пробежало А мы в
Африки посреди не знаю даже где в
каких-то джунглях мне даже если честно
страшно А это мой первый опыт проживания
в таком
[музыка]
месте а вчера ночью вы знаете друзья Я
лежал и всё думал думал столько было
мыслей и записывал их ещё раз
конспектировать знаете сегодня только
третий день обучения но я чувствую себе
такие большие изменения У меня столько
сил и энергии появилось это что-то
невероятное Давайте посмотрим что ещё
команда маргулан калича
[музыка]
nafa
Som Si
Si
sius
Si na
[музыка]
знаешь это было удивительно когда ты
видишь как Животные гуляют в стае вроде
там на расстоянии вытянутой руки живут
своей жизнью кайфуют А мы как раз со
стороны наблюдаем за их прекрасной
жизнью Я думаю каждый человек смотрел
National Geography когда-то хотел
оказаться в таком Сафари поэтому мечты
сбываются главное их правильно
загадывать поэтому это какая-то была на
самом деле ещё медитация ты как раз
едешь на джипе там лёгкое солнце с утра
Оно ещё было не сильно жаркое такой
какой-то звук деревьев каких-то жучков
Сверчков и так далее То есть Мы
оказались в какой-то такой э африканской
стране чудес под названием Джунгли не
действительно этих животных я их вот вот
на расстоянии утиной руки мы увидели это
было незабываемое щение Да и слияние с
природой Это потрясающе это какая-то
Седьмая поездка моя с маргуланом чем и
как всегда по теме путешествий они очень
яркие качественные
и комфортные в первую очередь Мне
нравится знания маргула калича вторую
очередь нравится Атмосфера всё что тут
происходит третью очередь Мне нравятся
люди которые его
окружают так как у них мышление совсем
другое и на основании их у меня есть в
том числе и я И вот четвёртая поездка но
в ЧМ большой плюс
умеет каждый раз удивлять Каждый раз он
даёт что-то новое либо он
дотавайн
и меньше мало того то что я знаю и здесь
я ещё приобретаю друзей Они такие
осознаны они такие классные и мы с ними
после уже часто встречаемся соз
Я здесь смотрите бизнес - это слуга Это
не самоцель это инструмент который
должен обеспечить вашу идеальную
жизнь это не так что вы служите
бизнесу бизнес должен служить вам Когда
у вас нету стандарта жизни то вы служите
бизнесу вы просто тупо зарабатываете
деньги а вам с А зачем вы говорите надо
короче
[музыка]
Я тко имею понимание и представление о
своей идеальной жизни и почему ты
занимаешься бизнесом для того чтобы
бизнес мне обеспечил эту идеальную жизнь
хитрость психологии нашей человеческой
психики в том что мы достигаем не тех
целей которые мы себе поставили а те
цели которые
понимаем Если мы не понимаем цель контур
не понимаем мы его не
достигаем лоз
до конт измеримых понятных ясных
коротких целей отличие удач от
неудачника в том что Удачник на один раз
стаёт больше так вот Я говорю вы
однозначно будете много раз падать
соответственно тогда возникает А когда
какой путь мне тогда выбрать надо
выбирать либо путь любимого дела потому
что из-за того что она Любимая ты будешь
вставать Сколько нужно падать вста
падать вставать падать
вставать прибыль сразу Здесь и сейчас
потому что эта прибыль будет тебе давать
мотивацию энергию каждый раз вставать
после падения всё не многие бизнесмены
говорят А какой нишей заняться что
продавать Я говорю это второе это второй
вопрос сначала нужно определиться Вот
это две дорожки Потому что 100% ты
будешь много раз падать твоя задача
вставать на один раз больше Поэтому либо
займись любимым делом либо займись тем
что сразу приносит прибыль
Да сегодня было очень интенсивное
обучение было очень много информации и я
думаю что после этого нужно обязательно
развеяться Но ведь не просто так я взяла
это платье
[музыка]
Я заметил что наши друзья участники
этого путешествия уже сближаются
раскрываются общаются друг с другом даже
уже сегодня мы как раз смеялись
несколько раз начинают заботиться и
помогать друг другу что очень даже
хорошо у меня это радует на самом деле
это одна из целей этого путешествия
чтобы люди сблизились подружились и
стали общаться после этого путешествия в
обычной жизни и для того чтобы их ещё
больше сблизить и чтобы они э ещё больше
общались друг с другом и стали друзьями
вот даже в обычной жизни после этого
путешествия мы для них приготовили ещё
кое-что интересное
[музыка]
Ну полёт - это было что-то с чем-то То
есть ты летишь над водопадом Виктория в
такой прекрасной компании с маргуланом
Калиевич и думаешь Вот оно счастье Я
столько этого ждала наконец мечта
сбылась это реально было круто и
незабываемо Я только что первый раз
полетал на вертолёте на самолёте
пробовал на вертолёте нет это просто
кайф мы пролетели над водопадом Виктория
пролетели над рекой Замбези и там были
Слоны и эти бегемоты и сам водопад видно
во всю его длину это настолько кайфово
вниз такими глазами и просто любовался
тем что там происходит я в какой-то
момент просто чуть не заплакал от этой
реальной красоты то есть впечатления
эмоции просто
зашкаливания коллективно игра называется
лодка остров Какое оптимальное рение вы
примете конда должна выработать самое
оптимальное по их мнению решение выбрать
кого из предложенных де человек
отправить на лодке за помощью А кого
оставить на острове дожидаться спасения
вра которы бере дож быть вме выживание
видишь они подметили билот на остро
Давай мы погане оставим на земле а
паганель нужен на лодке мале ло что
может проп человек на Земле остались
Лото Что кушать будеь базова Она не
имеет одного правильного ответа базова
потому что ни одна команда Какое бы вы
оптимальное решение Вы не приняли ваши
шансы вашей команды всё равно не
превысит условно говоря выше
75% Почему мы должны стремиться
увеличивать шансы при принятии каждого
решения Просто когда если мы будем на
протяжении жизни принимать 1000 решений
ися мы всё время будем работать над
увеличением шансов то в конечном итоге
конечно шанс сработает в вашу пользу
[музыка]
я закрыл одну из двух галочек прыгнул с
моста с резинкой Это был один из моих
самых больших страх просто хотел
прыгнуть не классно классное испытание
то есть но полёт был не не так долго или
мне показался он каким-то очень таким
знаешь буквально раздватри там да И тебя
уже ну начинает это
[музыка]
колбасить вот сейчас была у нас местная
Забава развлечение это катать колесо ку
и вот мы как Говори С моими
новоиспечённый
эту покрышку кстати очень замечательное
интересное занятие катать покрышку на
самом деле это прежде всего меня движет
любопытство посмотреть как устроен быт и
жизнь других народов потому что они тоже
в этом находят своё счастье Я сейчас
когда вовнутрь походил посидел с ними я
вполне их понимаю если бы я был один из
них то я вполне возможно был бы счастлив
поэтому счастье абсолютно никак не
связано с материальным богатством
главное здесь такая я смотрю Аура такая
деревня они очень все
дружные толпой бегают это же на самом
деле большое счастье Вот такая толпа
детей там сколько их вокруг нас бегает
штук 50 детей и они походу и футбол
играют и прятки играют и дерутся и всё
это и есть настоящее детство
[аплодисменты]
э поездка получилась очень замечательной
первый раз для себя открыл Африку я
как-то к ней относился более немножко
какими-то стереотипами что Африка
опасная страна что долго сложно
добираться но больше пора различные
болезни оказалась очень дружелюбная
страна которая нас тепло встретила и
как-то мы в этом отеле уже так здорово
проводим время что даже уезжать не
хочется очень понравилось от поездки
наше основное - Это команда команда
наших всех участников настолько быстро
как-то мы все сумели сблизиться
подружиться что время проведённое вместе
стало одним из самых интересных событий
всех этих поезды Это поездка которая
здесь это вообще отдельный мир то что мы
пережили и прожили а то что останется со
мной и я увезу Ну это конечно багаж
который я ещё буду разбирать наверное
долгое время и я очень рада что я здесь
что я участник все этой истории
Атмосфера больше всего запоминается
Атмосфера Здесь каждый
участник
раскрывается каждый день был очень
насыщенный мне кажется если эти дни
рассматривать то они были
самые плотные Если сравнивать весь год и
вот эти вот эта неделя то есть
максимальное количество событий эмоций
мы
прожили их было
зашкаливают общения для меня это прям
такая такое счастье оказаться среди
таких успешных перспективных
саморазвивающаяся
достигнуто Я конечно очень счастлива
вообще
невообразимо вниз и когда видела эти
брызги поднимающиеся со дна каньона это
что-то невероятное ты испытываешь такие
чувства впервые невероятно понравилось и
я думаю что эти впечатления останутся на
очень долгое время Мне кажется это
впечатление на всю жизнь
[музыка]
семью нашл не друзей семью Да всем всем
классно честно то есть даже наверно
больше чем семью то есть я очень рад что
приехал на это мероприятие что обрёл
таких друзей очень благодарна всем я
очень счастлива что я сюда попала Это
знаете как я жила на своей планете и
вдруг тебя так выпускают в космос и ты
такое не понимаешь что происходит но
тебе так кайфово и классно и понима что
всё у тебя всё впереди в этой жизни
Спасибо большое безумно благо и ра всеми
познакомиться за всю жизнь приоб такой
короткий отрезок времени столько друзей
Сколько за этот год То есть у меня три
путешествия Ну это просто колоссальное
количество новых друзей новых связе
возможностей подобного каждого
путешествия мы все я вам точно говорю
потому что я четвёртый раз так уже делал
мы все
никогда не будем
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
се